حشد وحشد المقابل في تركيا قبل اسبوعين
على الرابع عشر من مايو الذي ربما يكون
موعد الحسم في الانتخابات الرئاسيه الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان كان استانف السبت حملته
الانتخابيه ونشاطه العامه بعد وعكه صحيه
المت به الاسبوع الماضي حتى في انقره
مواطنيه ممن لم يحسم خيرهم بعد على
التصويت لصالحه كما توعد اردوغان مرشح
المعارضه وقال امام الالاف من مؤيديه في
العاصمه ان الشعب التركيه سيخرج مرشح
المعارضه من الحياه السياسيه وعدد لسكان
انقره ما قال انها انجازاته انقر باتت
عاصمه للصناعات الدفاعيه بفضل الاستثمارات
الحكوميه خلال العقدين الماضيين عملنا على
تطوير وتنميه انقره ورفع مستوى الرفاهيه
فيها على مدى عقدين شانها شان كفه مدن
تركيا الاخرى
غرب البلاد وفي مدينه ازمير معقل المعارضه
شدد زعيم ومرشح المعارضه كمارك على ان
الانتخابات خطوه على طريق اعاده بناء
الديمقراطيه التركيه متعهدا باعاده
الاستقرار للبلاد باصواتكم سنخرج تركيا من
هذا الوضع في عهد لن يكون هناك تمييز
ساحتضن 85 مليون تركي سواء صوته لي ام لا
يمكن للجميع التاكد من ان كمال سيكون الى
جانبكم جميعا
واردوغان يؤكدان على امكانيه الفوز من
الدوره الاولى الا ان التوقعات تشير الى
ترجيح حسم اسم الرئيس عبر دوره اقتراع
ثانيه تقام في الثامن والعشرين من مايو
حسن جوليد العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات